if you were alone in a room with someone
who willingly went through gay
conversion therapy what would you ask
[Music]
hey
hi
you feeling good i'm feeling great who
are you my name is chris would you mind
telling me a little bit about yourself
i'm 40 years old i live in los angeles i
was born and raised in canada i came to
the united states to study ballet
dancing and i was a professional dancer
for about 12 years what was the moment
that made you feel uh being gay was
wrong can you take me back there i'd
struggle with that my whole life i can't
pinpoint an exact moment because
i think i knew that i was gay from a
young age since i was like four or five
i always felt like it was not right you
know because i grew up in the church in
a conservative family and they had
certain expectations of genders and
sexual of our roles you know like
guys don't like guys that like girls as
far as the decision to go into
conversion therapy that was a decision i
made when i was about 19 years old and
what what was the deciding factor for
you to go to conversion therapy at 19.
um when i was 19 it was around the time
that uh 9 11 happened then i feel like a
lot of people felt very lost and felt
very scared there was a lot of like
uncertainty in the air and when that
happened i wasn't i was living far away
from my family i was still like
relatively
new to being on my own and so i was just
desperately seeking a sense of comfort
and a sense of like security and just
like someone to just protect me so i
thought i needed to go back to the
church to my faith but i felt like my
homosexuality you know being gay was
holding me back from having you know a
relationship with god so i decided at
that time to go into conversion therapy
that's when i spent two years in uh xk
ministry i don't look at it so much as
conversion therapy i look at it as like
healing sexual brokenness people
sometimes are just born gay and
sometimes i do think that they're
they're gay based on things that have
happened to them in their life
are you a devout christian i am a
christian i consider it one of the most
important things in my life i believe in
god i believe that jesus is the son of
god i believe that the only way to god
and to heaven is through his son jesus
christ so i believe like that school of
thought can you give me a little bit of
background on maybe what your childhood
was like
upbringing i grew up in a really
conservative family we were part of the
christian missionary alliance really
active in church and my mom and my dad
probably had more concern for me like
you know they still love me but they
didn't like the fact that i was gay i
think my family still kind of has that
attitude but it's not there's no tension
there like i think my family is still
pretty accepting of me and they still
love me regardless what did the gay
conversion therapy consist of was it
like just like counseling sessions was
it like overnight stays or anything like
that it was one-on-one counseling as
well as group meetings it was like a
faith-based program so i found it
beneficial i thought that it was good
because i i like the one-on-one
counseling and i like that you know
these were therapists that are you know
helping you work through things that
have happened in your life nothing
really traumatizing happened to me
sexually as a child but there's other
things in my life that they they sort of
feel like probably maybe made me gay i
don't know if you feel comfortable
saying you know all the things that went
on because i know that they do like
shock therapy and different tactics
would you say that there was a form of
abuse and then if there were abuse you
know were there any minors involved
because i know that a lot of teens young
adults get sent there so would you say
that it was child abuse in a way that's
one of the misconceptions with
conversion therapy that you know when
you sign up for conversion ever you're
going for shock treatment you're setting
up for a lobotomy someone would have
their license taken away like so quickly
if they what about mental abuse
in my experience there was never um any
type of demonizing of any behavior it's
based on love it's based in love like
that's what that's what their whole
mission is um based on love but
heterosexual love correct not like the
you know the quote love is love i don't
think that that would apply in this
instance because they're not saying love
is love they're saying love is a man and
a woman they're trying to work on like
self-love and like forming your identity
and who you are as a person
it should be in christ it shouldn't be
in your in who you have sex with so just
because they have sex with a guy or like
they have some type of intimacy with a
man or get drunk enough sex or kiss or
whatever that physical act may be that
doesn't mean necessarily that they're
gay because i think that the dance trade
the
definition of conversion therapy so my
knowledge is you know you are converting
someone who is homosexual homosexual
urges to heterosexual heterosexual urges
man and woman you know that kind of
thing so just to be clear would that be
your definition of conversion therapy
like um going from gated straight
there's this obsession in our culture to
just like
to know the answer to those questions
like this obsession of putting labels on
ourselves and each other i'm saying that
it's not as it's not always black and
white
do you want to elaborate on what you
specifically got out of like going
through gay conversion therapy i don't
know it just kind of helped me see
sexuality um sort of differently and i
think that maybe it wasn't necessarily
the best thing for me but i don't think
that it it's good to suppress that or to
like prevent anyone else from you know
exploring that if they they think that
it would help them so maybe some people
they have just a smaller attraction
towards men so they go into conversion
therapy because they kind of want to
work on those attractions so they can
have a relationship with a woman and a
sex life with their wife and lead that
kind of life so those are factors that
come into come into play when you're
defining who you are sexually you know
would you do it again
possibly i think
i'm at a weird place in my life where um
i would say that i'm gay just based on
the fact that i like to have sex with
men i left conversion therapy um
in my early 20s and then after that i
went into the world of adult
entertainment and i did porn and
escorting and traveled the world for
about eight years do you mind me asking
what what kind of porn you did yeah i
did on gay porn and i did over 150
movies
so
does that go against what the conversion
therapy was about like did they say
being gay was wrong it's very
complicated if you figure out some time
in your life that okay i'm gay i like
sex with the same sex i want to live
that life i'm going to get married to
you know a man and i'm a man um we all
end up in that place for different
reasons and it's not the same for
everyone queerness homosexuality
this like spectrum of sexuality the
spectrum of gender you think that's a
bad thing that we're pushing for the
normalization of those things this whole
idea that um
you know it's all about love love is
love man like just love what you want to
love it's like i feel like that's the
problem and that's toxic and i feel like
why because
love is love okay so here's the thing
you gotta you have a girl who's like
madly in love with this boyfriend that
beats the [ __ ] out of her all the time
and you know she stays with him for
years she keeps trying to leave him she
can't it's like this you know toxic
[ __ ] up relationship love is love it's
just about love it's like no love is a
feeling and i think that you cannot base
your life and your decisions on a
feeling because feelings change all the
time just because you label something as
love doesn't mean that it's right and
that's what i feel like there's this
push to do it's like so you think being
gay is wrong
that's what it makes me sound like that
you're comparing
homosexuality to an abusive boyfriend
when i think those two things are
different
i can only speak for me because i'm one
gay person i do not speak for all the
gay people right you know at first yes
when you are coming out in your
sexuality it is something that you're
struggling with and something that you
know you're battling you don't really
know okay do i like girls don't like
guys i don't know what i like my family
don't like me it's all these different
emotions that you have and then you got
the world going on you got the world's
opinions you got everybody down your
throat asking what you want to do and
you know when you finally do come out
and you realize okay this is what i like
this is who i love it feels like a
weight is lifted off your shoulders if
you can't love yourself you don't love
nobody else so for me being gay is being
proud of who you are what you represent
so yeah i understand what you're saying
but i just think it's pushing the gay
community in the lgbt community it's
become very militant and it's become
very oppressive in the way that they
think it's like if you don't believe
these certain beliefs or these certain
values or morals or whatever then you're
sort of like rejected from the gay
community and that's where i kind of
feel like i'm in right now and that's
what i don't like and i feel like it's
happening more and more to people
something that i think is kind of doom
and gloom right now in the world are the
laws that specifically especially in the
united states that target queer people
um in florida with the don't say gay
bill and in texas with the bills trying
to attack trans
children like how do you feel about like
those laws and kind of like the laws
about conversion therapy that people are
trying to like outlaw conversion therapy
so i believe that the whole this whole
ban
on conversion therapy i feel like it's a
huge waste of time i feel like it's sort
of being used as a distraction the thing
is commercial therapy is something that
some people are willingly choosing to go
into because they're not content with
like their sexuality or the way things
are going in their life not everyone was
there because they struggled with
same-sex desires there was like men that
were had been cheating on their wife and
they had you know obsessions or
addictions to porn so they want to work
on these issues you know and i think
what's even worse than conversion
therapy is this active push to like ban
conversion therapy because i think the
government is using that as a way to
suppress the voice of like the church or
certain therapists and not allowing them
to
say what they want to say and believe
what they want to believe and i feel
like that's even worse than conversion
therapy is trying to control what people
say and people think people should be
able to explore that if they want and
decide if it's right for them because i
feel everyone's situation is different
um if you could press a button and
become straight would you uh yeah
probably
why
so i'm 40 almost 41. things aren't
necessarily
bad in my life but i feel like i've kind
of done this whole gay thing and if i
could change it i'd be like yeah change
it because i'd like to see what it'd be
like to be straight and have a wife and
have kids yeah i'll share that i i did
some form of conversion therapy myself
for years ever since i was a kid i
prayed that god take this sin away it
wasn't until i got to a place of real
depression similar to you except my
my answer was to lean into
who i am and i was laying in my bed
depressed my skin started changing
colors terribly that's how stressed i
was and i heard the voice of god say get
up and be who i called you to be
whoever is going to love you will love
you and whoever doesn't just won't
and still after that after i came out i
could not answer the question of whether
i was going to go to hell
yeah i actually asked a group of
ministers who were proud queer ministers
imams priests
in the buddhist community and i asked
how do you all know you made the right
decision how do you all know that you
won't spend an eternity in hell
and unfortunately
not many of them had an answer you know
people debate whether or not being gay
is the result of nature or nurture you
know i feel like that's a it's an
ongoing debate because we really don't
know and i think that it it doesn't
matter because i feel like even if it's
if it's nature then if we're gay because
of it's a result of all this bad stuff
that's happened to us and things that
were beyond our control then why would
god punish us for that i don't think he
will i was born gay nothing bad happened
to me no traumatic experience and what i
learned and how being gay became the
biggest sin in the world is because of
messaging right the word homosexual did
not get into the bible until 1946
you talked about building a relationship
with god
and you felt being gay kept you from
that relationship
what changed
at that time i still viewed being gay
and
homosexuality as a sin and i felt like
sin is what separates us from god what
changed i came back to my faith i would
say about three or four years ago and um
it's been a positive experience and i've
sort of made peace with this whole idea
that i have to change my my sexuality my
sexual identity if i'm going to be a
christian because i don't feel like it's
necessarily as big of a deal as people
may get out to be in this in our culture
today and i don't think that it's as big
of a deal to god there's this push in
our culture to like be obsessed with
like am i gay am i straight and then if
i'm gay i have to have gay sex and have
a gay lifestyle and like you know do
these things and it's not necessarily
the case i just need to maybe chill out
and kind of let things happen
organically and not stress about you
know what label they have or what their
sexuality is
chris nice to meet you good to meet you
thanks for coming out yeah sure of
course
appreciate it
[Music]